hi I'm Ryan I'm gonna be watching the
trailer for a Maleficent damn I'm now
I'm unconfident if I got it right this
would be the third trailer I'm watching
for this and I keep forgetting how to
pronounce the damn thing I'm pretty sure
it's Maleficent I've had a lot of people
try sounding it out for me through
typing words down there where I cannot
hear them everyone's saying this is the
best one this is the best trailer all
these trailers are super short so let's
get this show on the road
PS Angelina Jolie wanna bang her saving
this hell she looks like she's gonna
have a ball of a time
pretty sure this is exactly what
happened to me you film as this dark
town it's gonna rock
oh cool
okay I'm on board
there is evil in this world hatred and
revenge
hey old fish okay I don't have like big
chills but I got like minor chills you
know cuz honestly the first two trailers
that is movie look like [ __ ]
but that one made the film look pretty
cool I'm hoping it has more of that kind
of tone they be kind of it's like very
tail thing I like the darkness darker is
better that's all cinema knows these
days